Y en crónica política,
relacionado de alguna manera también con la educación,
el partido socialista
reivindica que el presupuesto municipal
se invierta en mejorar el bienestar de las familias
ilicitanas. Los socialistas
recalcan la importancia de que las cuentas
para 2 024 se destinen a la vivienda,
la educación y el apoyo al pequeño comercio.
Héctor 10, portavoz del PSOE,
ha planteado algunas propuestas
para el próximo presupuesto municipal
que se debatirá en el pleno del 22 de diciembre.
Ha recalcado
que se destine en ayudar a ilicitanos e ilicitanas
que viven de alquiler
y que se incrementen las ayudas al pago de Libi.
Además, los socialistas piden que se destinen €750 000
a las reformas de los centros educativos
y que se establezcan unas ayudas
en forma de paquetes de apoyo al inicio escolar.
10 ha especificado que
también se deben poner en marcha
programas de ayuda al pago del alquiler,
ya que son más de 20 000 personas las afectadas,
y que estén destinadas a familias con rentas bajas y 2ª
que permitan aliviar el bolsillo
la ciudadanía que paga 1 alquiler.
El PSOE cifra la subida del alquiler en Elche en 1/2,
del 16 por 100.
Además, el portavoz socialista
ha hecho hincapié
en el amparo a los pequeños comercios,
con €300 000
destinados a programas de innovación y digitalización
para que Sean más competitivos en el día a día.
Por otro lado,
ha propuesto que se genere
1 nueva edición de los bonos.
Consumo de 1,5 millones de euros
en El presupuesto municipal
para gastar en el pequeño comercio.
Por último 10
ha explicado que
es necesario que el presupuesto se refuerce
con €500 000
para los colectivos sociales que apoyan a las personas
más vulnerables.
Tenemos que centrarnos en las dificultades
que tiene la ciudadanía
y estas pasan
por la vivienda,
por lo educativo,
por el apoyo al pequeño comercio y desde luego,
también por lo social,
fundamentalmente porque consideramos que
los problemas del día a día
son aquellos que tenemos a la hora
de afrontar los gastos de la vivienda.
Son aquellos también que están relacionados
con las dificultades
y con el incremento de precios en el material escolar
y por supuesto,
también lo relacionados con nuestro pequeño comercio,
porque en Navidad podemos poner muchas luces,
pero si no apoyamos al pequeño comercio, al final
nuestras calles serán tristes
y el pequeño comercio desaparecerá